One of my assistants that
traveled with me, he said,
after all these years, this
still gets to you, doesn't it?
I said, man, we putting
a man's body in there
next to his mother's grave.
Yeah, it gets to me.
And I said, let me tell
you something, young man.
The minute it doesn't
matter to you any more
you need to leave the movement.
It matters to me.
Every one of these deaths.
Hello and welcome.
If you want a long view of the battle
for racial justice and equality,
there are few better
witnesses than my guest today.
He went from pounding
the streets of America
demanding change,
to having a direct line
to the White House.
Attracting strong praise
and sharp criticism
for his style and tactics along the way,
he is the civil rights veteran,
the Reverend Al Sharpton,
who has been on the frontline
of many of America's most
notorious police brutality cases,
including caring for George Floyd's family
as Black Lives Matter protests
erupted around the world.
Soul legend James Brown
was a father figure to him.
And now aged 67
with a weekly TV and daily
radio show to his name,
he shows no signs of slowing down.
He now has his latest book
out, "Righteous Troublemakers,"
in which he tells the stories
of those who have
protest thrown upon them.
Reverend Al, thank you very
much for being with me.
And I thought I'd start by asking,
is that how you describe yourself,
a righteous troublemaker?
Well, I do.
I think that it is,
You know I got the thought
of it from John Lewis,
who was of course the Congressman
and beloved in the civil rights movement.
He said, make good trouble.
And I think that I've tried to be
a good troublemaker all my life.
We'll come to your record
and how that's worked
and some of the tactics and
how things have changed.
But who are you trying to
give voice to in this book?
I'm trying to give voice to people
that I feel made tremendous contributions
but never got the recognition
and the visibility that I
think that they were merited.
For example,
most people in the United States
and in around the Western world
would not know the name
of Claudette Colvin.
Claudette Colvin,
whose story I write about in this book,
was arrested for sitting
in front of the bus
in segregated Montgomery, Alabama,
refusing to give up her seat,
nine months before Rosa Parks.
But the local Montgomery black leadership
didn't want to rally around her
because they said she was too dark skinned
and she was pregnant and was unmarried.
She didn't have the moral
picture they wanted.
It was her sitting in the front of the bus
that inspired Rosa Parks.
In fact, Fred Gray was the
lawyer for both of them.
And I wanted people to understand that,
so that everyday people would know
that you don't have to qualify
to be a troublemaker or a freedom fighter.
Everybody has a contribution.
And these people were just regular people
that did some things that were amazing.
And yet some of the people
that you're also talking about in the book
have protest thrust upon them.
It's not something that
they set out to do,
and because they find themselves
a miscarriage of justice
and they find themselves
in the eye of the storm.
How have you found their stories?
And at times I know you've
personally worked with them
and tried to get them ready
for something like that.
They're ordinary people
living just regular lives.
And all of a sudden
they're thrust out here
in the middle of what becomes a maelstrom.
I talk about Philonise Floyd for example.
Philonise was just a regular
guy in Houston, Texas.
Brother George Floyd abused
by police in Minneapolis.
And all of a sudden
they become a global news story
And a global movement
But Philonise, unlike me or unlike others,
didn't choose to be an activist.
He's thrust out there.
And that's one of the reasons
why National Action Network
has been involved in a lot of these cases,
is you have to remember
when a police officer
is accused of a misdeed or a crime,
they have the police
unions that back them up
and provide them with
lawyers and resources
and if they need a therapist,
if they need people to
help them with interviews
or to advise them with media.
Families have none of that.
They wake up one morning,
and their brother, their
cousin, their son is dead.
Nobody's there to help them.
That's why National Action
Network provides all of that
because you need an institution
to go up against the institutions.
And we can provide all of that.
You're talking there
about the organization
that you head up to, which helps people?
Exactly.
I mean, you say in the book,
your job was to build
a firewall of support
around the Floyd family
to guide, to protect them.
I mean, even though what
had happened was horrendous
and then became the symbol
of a newly-ignited kind
of global movement,
do you think that they
could be prepared for it?
I mean, are they still sort
of coming out of that now?
I think that they showed tremendous growth
and tremendous ability,
but they had to have people
that would advise and guide them.
So the perception is that,
oh, with people like Sharpton and others
run in when there is trouble.
No, we'll call them.
The Floyd family called me.
I mean, can you imagine you
are mourning your brother?
In Philonise's case. Philonise Floyd.
Brother was killed.
How he was killed,
you're watching on television every night,
and how this is killing you.
But there's 10 TV
cameras outside your door
that wants an immediate response.
And you don't know if you'll say something
that might hurt the case
that you want prosecuted
or just the policemen.
So you need people that will say,
be careful, don't say this.
Don't say something out of
rage that they can use later.
All of that comes with
building a movement.
And all of that happens
to people that decide
I'm going to make trouble
for a system that's unfair
but I'm going to do it in a righteous way.
And that's why I talk about it.
I got the idea
because when in the
middle of George Floyd,
since we're talking about it,
they had asked me to do the eulogy
at both his funeral in Houston
and his funeral in Minneapolis.
And I remember in the middle
of my delivering the eulogy,
just for whatever reason, it hit me,
because I've always been
an extemporaneous speaker
because I started
preaching when I was a kid.
So I don't use a manuscript.
And it hit me, and I said, we
need to march on Washington.
We need to bring the
issue of police reform
and police misconduct to Washington.
We had over 200,000 people.
And I'm on my way to the steps
where Dr. King had spoken in 1963
to make the speech.
I have the families of
George Floyd with me.
Family of Ahmaud Arbery with me.
Family of Jacob Blake.
Family of Breonna Taylor.
About 15 victim's families.
We're all walking toward the stage.
And in these throngs of people,
I see an old man that
was jumping up and down
with an object in his hand,
trying to get my attention.
And I say to the security
around me, I said,
What is that old man trying to tell me?
And then he says,
Well, Reverend, we need
to keep you moving.
And I said, No, but this old man,
he looks like he's in his eighties.
He's trying to say something. Go get him.
And they went and got
him, brought him to me.
And he showed me what he had
in his hand was a button.
And it said, "March on
Washington. Freedom now."
He said, I was here in '63
with Martin Luther King
and I wanted to be here today with you.
And this is the button I wore in '63.
And that kind of haunted
me. I never forgot that man.
Because he just went back in the crowd.
And I said, there are people
that have paid a price,
that went to the marches,
went to the rallies,
some went to jail,
some were killed,
that knew they were never
going to be in the newspaper
the next day.
They were not going to be
on the news that night.
They were just righteous troublemakers.
They were there for the cause.
Suppose the people like me
called a march and nobody came.
These people came.
200,000 people in the middle of a pandemic
at their own expense, at their own risk.
Why don't we that have the limelight
put a limelight on some of them.
And that's where the
book's concept came from.
On that point though,
I was wondering when you get that call,
you yourself because you have
been doing this for so long,
faith is obviously a
huge part of your life.
How do you deal with that?
Because you're still seeing
people losing their lives.
You're still seeing these
police brutality cases.
I think if I didn't have a
deep spiritual life and faith,
it would overtake me
because it hurts to
stand over these funerals
and look at these bodies
over and over again.
I've done since George Floyd
maybe 10 funerals of victims since then.
There's no way that would not wear on you
unless you had a faith to believe
that this is the work
that you were born to do.
I'm watching families.
I'm trying to comfort them
and at the same time asking myself,
God, how long will this last?
How many times do we
have to go through this
before the laws are changed?
So if I were to tell
you it didn't get to me,
I would be lying.
I tell you, and I wrote
about this in the book,
after George Floyd's funeral,
the last one in Houston,
and we had the long motorcade to bury him
next to his mother.
And I remember I did the prayer.
I did the committal of the body.
And then I hugged the family
and I left to head to the
airport to head back to New York.
And I had my head down
and a little teary-eyed.
And one of my assistants that
traveled with me, he said,
after all these years, this
still gets to you, doesn't it?
I said, man, we putting
a man's body in there
next to his mother's grave.
Yeah, it gets to me.
And I said, let me tell
you something, young man.
The minute it doesn't
matter to you any more,
you need to leave the movement.
It matters to me.
Every one of these deaths.
How much do you feel faith is
baked into the politics of America though?
Because it's very distinct
when you're looking in
that it's so linked.
And you can see people on
different political sides
defending their views
or using sometimes Christianity
in particular to say,
this is God's will.
Do you think that faith
is being weaponized
in American politics in a
way that is just unhealthy?
I think that it is
definitely being weaponized
in a way that's unhealthy,
because I think that we've used faith
as a way of making people other than us,
or that others then believe,
wicked, and therefore,
if you can make them wicked
and make them some kind of
anti what God would want,
that it justifies treating them unequally
and treating them unfairly,
which is why I think people
of faith have to say,
I'm motivated by my faith,
but I want to protect people's rights
that may not even have a faith.
I remember when I came
out for LGBTQ rights,
many, many years ago,
and I even supported gay marriage,
some of the clergymen that I preached for
in their churches as a guest minister
said to me, Reverend Al,
I don't know if we could have
you in the church this year
because a lot of our parishioners
are not with you on
that same-sex marriage.
And I said, well, okay,
then I'm not coming.
I think when there is just
a blurring of the lines
as there still seems to
be in America at times
with faith and with politics,
I mean, it can be that people
do not see it as the law.
They see it as imposing
people's views on them.
And I wonder what you
think would come first,
an atheist president of
America or a female president?
Well, I probably would
say a female president.
But I don't rule it out.
I mean, when I got started as
a youngster in the movement,
I never thought I'd see a black president.
So it would not shock me
that either would come,
but my guess would be a female president.
We already now have a
female vice president.
Indeed. Well, it's still not happened.
But I suppose whatever
political side you're on,
the candidate has to believe in God
and has to prove it in some way,
which is striking regardless
of how you come at it.
Just talking about the phrase
"righteous troublemaker,"
and I was thinking about what happened
just over a year ago on the Capitol.
Those rioters would
probably describe themselves
in a similar way as
righteous troublemakers.
They believe in what they are doing.
They believe in what they're marching for.
And I suppose what would you say
being someone who's
protested your whole life
and being so divided
from those with a view
who have of what they're doing
being just as worthy as what you're doing?
I would say to them that
what will make the difference
of whether what you're doing
is righteous or unrighteous
is the end goal.
What are you trying to do?
They were there that day, January 6th,
to stop the certification of an election
that the American people
had chosen a president.
If you're going to have a righteous cause,
the end, the goal must be righteous,
and your behavior to achieve
the goal must be righteous.
Neither was the case in the
January 6th insurrection.
Because some say what
happened on the Capitol
was the beginning of something,
not the end of something,
and 75 million people voted
for Trump in the last election.
And I just wondered from your
side of things, as it were,
how do you see this playing out
if the sides just can't
talk to each other?
Because you've built movements.
I think that
I agree with those that say January 6th
was the beginning of something.
They are not going anywhere.
They have gone into states,
now changing voting laws.
They have built an infrastructure
around this big lie that Trump really won,
and that they want to in some way
control how votes are counted
and how votes are done.
I think we're in for a long season
of confronting voting
rights and different sides
opposing different sides
on these questions.
And I don't know that
we are going to be able
to get to this dialogue of
healing for a minute now.
I think this is going to play itself out.
I think the election of Joe Biden
and the four years of Donald Trump
has divided the United States
more than I've seen it in my lifetime.
Looking at movements then,
and looking at how things
can hopefully get better or improve.
Of course, as I say,
you've been protesting,
you've been on the streets
for a long, long time.
And you've seen things that
you couldn't have imagined,
like a black president,
like you just said.
But I was just thinking about
tactics and changing approach.
Of course, many hailed the
Black Lives Movement protests
because they didn't erupt in violence.
They didn't erupt in riots,
although there have also
been divisions within that.
Some factions calling for
the defunding of the police.
Just a word on that.
Where are you on that?
And where do you think
the movement is on that?
Because there is division.
I think as any movement,
there's always going to be
disagreements within the movement.
I grew up in the north.
The year Martin Luther
King was killed, I was 13.
I was already youth director
of his chapter in New York.
There are people that
disagreed with Dr. King.
They're saying that they
believed in self-defense,
not non-violence.
They believed in...
Then you had those on the other side
that had condemned Dr. King
for coming out against the war in Vietnam,
saying that we should be
for whatever President Johnson wanted
because he was a good
civil rights president.
So, these disagreements exist.
I think that we need to reform the police,
but we need to keep a measure
of policing in our communities
because we have high crimes.
You've got as much a
problem with gun violence
as you have a problem
of dealing with police
that are over the line and
do things that are wrong
and that in many cases are criminal.
Also, I think that it is restructuring
how you put the funds and
how you fund policing.
But you must have policing.
Three weeks after I did the eulogy
for George Floyd's funeral,
I did the eulogy of a one-year-old child
that was killed in a crossfire
of gangs fighting in Brooklyn.
So we need both.
We need good policing, funded properly,
that deal with things like
mental health and gun control.
And there's also of
course this push and hope
that the police themselves
will report bad cops,
will also come forward
and have that culture change within there,
as well as the training and the policing
that they've got to do
that you talk about.
I'm just thinking about people
who may be thinking of themselves
in the way that you've described,
a righteous troublemaker,
talking about making good trouble,
as you said right at the
beginning of our conversation.
And if you think back to your younger self
and how you've changed as a
protestor and your tactics,
what is your biggest regret,
and what's the lesson you've learned?
What I've learned is
that you should not shoot from the hip.
We often say tit-for-tat.
Report or somebody say something,
I'm almost at the beginning
of their last word,
answering them,
be more thoughtful to
make sure whatever you say
and whatever you do and
whatever tactics you use
is toward achieving the
end goal that you profess.
Because people are depending on you.
And they expect you to be thoughtful,
not just theatrical.
One of the controversies
that is still brought up by
your critics is your response
to the 1991 Crown Heights
riots in New York.
To remind our viewers,
these took place after a
seven-year-old black boy
was killed in a motorcade
by a motorcade transporting a rabbi.
Violence broke out after that death
and a Jewish student was killed.
Your critics say you never
called on the rioters
to stop their
anti-Semitic-inspired violence.
Is that fair?
That's totally erroneous.
Because as the state of
New York did a study,
I was not even in Crown Heights
when the young rabbi student was killed.
I was called by the family
of the seven-year-old kid the next day.
But many in the fringe or
right wing try and distort
that I somehow should've called for them
not to do what they did that night,
when I was living in New Jersey.
But these are the kinds of
things that you have to deal with
and you keep going.
That is not only unfair. It's untrue.
That's why I wanted to ask you about it.
I mean, you did mark the 20th
anniversary of the incident.
You wrote an opinion piece
in the New York Daily News and you said,
our language and tone
sometimes exacerbated tensions
and played to the extremists.
And actually there was a response
from the young man's brother,
who responded saying,
he felt your recollections
were sanitized and distorted.
So there's obviously still
a lot of hurt and pain.
But again, we're talking 30
what? How many years ago?
All you have to do is
go to the state report,
who, by the way, criticized David Dinkins,
the mayor then, and others,
but said Sharpton was not there.
Now I said that when I came in
that maybe I could have,
as I did the eulogy for the
seven-year-old kid's funeral,
said more things that would have been
that I would just,
they would say differently.
But to say that I incited
or excused violence,
it's just not true.
And even in his brother's statement,
saying sanitize or whatever,
as a matter of opinion,
he could not say that I incited violence.
I suppose it's just when
you are looking back
at tactics and how protests happen
and the leadership I
suppose that you've had,
it's about also learning from that,
which is what I wanted to ask you about,
because you'll be well aware
of these criticisms over the years.
Right, I think that what I've
learned and what I share,
just keep your eye on the prize.
What is it that you're going for?
Don't react to the crowd.
Don't play to the -
Mrs. Martin Luther King, Coretta
Scott King used to tell me,
don't play to the cheap seats
to get the roaring of the crowd.
She said, think about what
you're trying to achieve
and speak to that.
And that's what I've had to learn.
I just wanted to ask about
the next generation of leaders
that you have in your sights,
particularly around racial equality.
Are there some that you are
particularly keeping an eye on?
I have many in my National Action Network
and some beyond that I'm looking at.
I won't call names
but there are some that
are very impressive.
And I tell them that they've got to learn
in their generation what works
and they're going to be tested
and you're going to be criticized.
And being a troublemaker,
you're going to have trouble,
because the fact that you're questioning,
speaking truth to power,
power isn't going to answer you.
So make sure you are absolutely committed
and want to be that and do that.
But keep your eye on the prize.
Don't make my mistakes.
You can study people like me and others,
but study also where we fell short
and correct them as we go.
And also health I imagine.
You have an amazing regime.
You can keep going for longer I suppose.
If you don't mind me mentioning,
you've lost an enormous amount of weight
and you post about drinking
your kale juice every day
and you look great.
I've lost 176 pounds
over the last four years.
I am a vegetarian.
Eat one meal a day.
Work out 35 minutes every morning.
And I'm in better shape
now at 67 than I was at 37.
Well, long may it continue.
And do you work out
listening to James Brown?
Of course, a few gym grooves?
A lot of times I do.
He was like my dad.
First time I went to London,
James Brown brought me.
He played at the Hammersmith Odeon.
And I worked with James Brown.
He brought me to London and I listened.
A lot of his music is up-tempo.
So it helps me when I'm on the elliptical
or lifting weights.
That's what you're doing it to.
Reverend Al Sharpton,
thank you very much indeed for your time,
your recollections, and
some of your lessons.
Thank you. God bless.
Thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
mask up, stay safe,
and goodbye.